why is a third party the answer i have a
poster on the breaking point set of
william jennings brian somebody i deeply
respect who essentially was a third
party candidate but who transformed and
took over the democratic party in the
1890s um donald trump in many ways the
most transformative political figure of
my lifetime had no connection with the
institutional gop but effectively took
it over from the outside and remade it
in his own image why not andrew you are
famous you've run in the presidential
primary you had the proven ability to
raise tens of millions of dollars in the
democratic party more so than many
establishment figures why not leverage
your part of that democratic party and
try and take it over from within why is
this the answer you have to go with
soccer i think that your importance in
the media landscape can't be understated
you too marshall crystal uh when you say
like hey there's a sizeable audience for
this
um i think there is a massive audience
and it heartens me that that audience
continues to grow uh because a lot of
folks say to me in normal life be like
hey i don't even know where to go for
news anymore um and and some you know
and some of them have found you
and uh
um other independent voices and i think
that's so necessary i think if we can
continue to grow that point of view then
it can become more of a political force
um
now i i think that you've actually
articulated in some ways a dynamic that
would strengthen the need to have more
political dynamism and multiple parties
so donald trump has taken over the
republican party um i know when you know
that there are many people who have
different points of view than donald
trump within the party but don't breathe
a word because if they do they will be
cast out and
um their political careers will be ended
and why is that it's because we have
this two-party system and uh you know
party primaries control so much and that
if you say a bad word about trump uh
you're out i'm gonna suggest that's not
excellent for
democracy generally um and then you have
the democratic party and you say hey
andrew why don't you just take over the
democratic party trump style so right
now the big difference between democrats
and republicans is that democrats are
institutionalists and republicans are
not i cannot tell you how many
independents and republicans came up to
me and be like hey man i love you like
you know like way to like go against uh
you know the
entrenched machine and the rest of it um
but within the democratic party
they really believe in bureaucracies and
machines and processes to a much much
higher degree and here's a stat that i
think
illustrates the difference between the
parties
69 of democrats say they have a high
trust in media by media you know
generally the corporate media right
independence 36
republicans 15
so republicans don't believe it all and
does they think that oh like the you
know the institutions are are uh corrupt
now to get us the democrats are the
people who believe in it and are just
like oh yeah like you know that things
are going all right like just let the
you know people who've been doing it for
a while keep doing it um so you have
very very different dynamics uh and it's
going to influence who winds up emerging
from uh each side
something
i'm wondering is
what do independents
actually believe because i love the 62
percent
gallup poll looking for a third party
we'll put it up in the show notes but if
you actually look into the data it gets
a little interesting given the fact that
for example a decent number of those
independents are
former republicans who actually want the
republican party to become more trumpy
not less
another interesting thing that came to
mind when you're talking about how you
get drummed out of the republican party
if you don't vote for trump is the fact
that
liz cheney
actually voted with trump more if an
elite stefanik did
so there's a certain weird mix of
personalities and coalitions and
dynamics but i guess what i kind of
wonder is if we're actually looking at
the country and the results of the
politics that we're engaging in
considering the fact that liz cheney
actually does once again
vote pretty conservative
aside from the trump thing how is giving
her her own tiny coalition party they
would end up still working with the
republican party on most questions once
again she votes with trump most of the
time far more of it or competitorly
stephonic how would that change things
especially when we're talking about the
big big issues here so for example the
supreme court let's say you have a
progressive party and a center-left
democratic party they're going to fight
about climate change they're going to
fight with the green new deal they're
going to fight about the 3.5 trillion
dollar budget package but they are going
to vote in lockstep on supreme court
nominees and that is a type of vote
which seems to be drawing or causing the
civil war level conflict we're afraid of
here so how do you just reflect on all
that
i think that if you had uh let's call
them moderate republicans or something
like that um that that was like a
non-trump uh alternative
i think they might vote along with trump
over and over again on a lot of things
but they might diverge from him on
things like
uh
vote counts or like constitutional
protections of elections or or things
like that
um i'm going to suggest that's a very
crucial distinction
that if you had uh
the republicans that were ready to do
that then i think we'd be in better
shape
and
that's a positive
uh that's one of the reasons why i think
we need to build a more resilient system
again and
you if you build a system like this and
uh it's
now much more susceptible to
authoritarianism and under democratic
impulses than most people would imagine
and
we can change that we can fix it we
don't have unlimited time in my opinion
but we should really work on it
do it as quickly as possible um but it's
not about every vote it's about certain
principles that
might be extraordinarily
valuable to to our country in our
democracy
andrew one thing i want you to reflect
on is policy you know when you ran you
were the policy candidate you had the
math hats i used to really believe um in
policy that people would vote on policy
but as the elections went on and as i
saw trump win 10 million more votes as i
start to see you know stuff turn on
questions of do you think the election
was stolen or not as opposed to did
trump do anything to actually better
your life
i honestly got pretty uh i was pretty
black-pilled on the whole thing and i
guess my question to you is does policy
matter at all um whenever it comes to
these because as you point to and as
marshall just alluded to 62 say that
they want a third party really what that
is is they're holding a middle finger up
and saying i hate the system and i've
always ascribed trump's success
to nothing that he's ever actually done
in office and just directionally being
the voice that agrees with the majority
of the public who say i hate our
institutions and it was really upsetting
to me
to learn that that was enough for
millions of people to cast their vote
for president of the united states
how have you reflected on that from when
you announced your polity or run on
policy and are almost in an age where
it's not the defining you know
uh it's not the defining issue of our
time
saga i go into this in my book in some
detail as you know and i had a similar
awakening or grappling as you
and in ezra's book why we're polarized
he talks about how
the correlation between the way people
vote and their policy desires are
actually very low
it's only like .25 where right um so
you're not voting on policy uh what are
you voting on you're voting on tribalism
and identity and
anger and
uh the kind of um
energy that a candidate gives off and
their attitude towards institutions and
so this is one of the things that i
grapple with in my book
and i've identified as the reason why i
need to start the forward party and make
it a success
is that there is a band of people that
did respond to me and my campaign uh the
policy vision
the facts
and what happened was that we activated
a certain group of people that like that
kind of thing
maybe they like me maybe they like my
you know like my particular energy and
when i started out i thought i'd be
received a certain way
i thought i'd be seen as very very lefty
because you know i was talking about
giving everyone money um but it turns
out that i have a very different vibe
maybe because i've run businesses maybe
because i seem kind of
practical
and so it turns out there's like a lane
for the practical person
and when you talk about the things that
are animating voters uh i i now see
myself as someone who can activate a
tribe and i was joking with some people
that it's like look do i think that 51
percent of people love this language i
speak of
facts and rationality and fixing systems
and the rest of it it's like probably
not
but do i think that
10 of americans love it and that 10
percent can do a ton of good in a
country that's polarized the way ours is
and the answer to that is hell yeah you
know it's like i if if i get
my band of rational
solutions oriented
backs driven people together
and then we can come in and say look
let's fix the system so it'll actually
work for everyone and it's more
resistant to bad things and
you know more pro compromise the
incentives are more rational
i'm at heart
uh an operator type and if you arrive at
a system and you see that the system is
going to produce terrible results and oh
by the way that's what we're getting and
that and in this case those terrible
results will actually eventually have us
at each other's throats i'm sure i'll um
be like throwing things at
you and marshall no i'm just kidding but
uh but um you know like if you arrive on
the scene and that's the system then the
right thing to do is be like all right
let's fix the system and then if the
systems run in this case by this duopoly
you'd be like all right how do we fix
the system let's run by this duopoly
and the answer is something like the
forward party which is going to try and
get into the guts of our system fix the
mechanics
now to do that we're going to have to
ignite a popular movement
so let's get started
[Music]
you